es ist in vielen teilen deutschlands das
heißeste wochenende des jahres bis zu 36
grad werden erwartet millionen menschen
drängt es nach draußen an die
schwimmbäder an die strände in den
eigenen garten alles ist voll und trotz
der einschränkungen gibt es gute
nachrichten denn laut einer israelischen
studie hilft uns die sonne gegen korona
zu kämpfen verantwortlich dafür ist das
vitamin d und was das mit unserem körper
macht darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen
mit doktor thomas aßmann erst mir jetzt
zugeschaltet herr doktor ist man ja was
macht denn die sonne oder das vitamin d
mit unserem körper und wie kann uns das
gegen korona helfen
das war ja schöne grüße nach berlin bei
uns hier im rheinland jetzt schon also
ich glaube ist ja nur ein bisschen
sonnenschein die sonne haben sie recht
ist wichtig deswegen weil vitamin d
gebildet
vitamin d soll nicht nur für die knochen
aufbaut und sein sondern auch eine
positive psychische wirkung kam aber
nicht zu vergessen ist auch das so
genannte serotonin was nach aufgebaut
wird der termin ist so anführungszeichen
glückshormon dass wir uns dann besser
fühlen und wie gesagt der kleine macht
haben natürlich das melatonin das ist
das schlafhormon wird er abgebaut
bedeutet wir sind fitter lade aber
natürlich auch für die nacht und damit
auch für die partys und in wie sein kann
uns das jetzt helfen schwere verläufe
von corona zu verhindern
also man muss natürlich so sagen dass
die sonne direkten natürlich nicht so
die verläufe ausüben kann aber natürlich
wenn wir eine gute kondition haben weil
wir eine gute psychische stabilität
haben ist das auf alle fälle schon
besser als wenn wir mit einer schlechten
konstruktion wenn wir mit depressiven
seiten in einer krankheitswelle reihen
laufen oder in einer krankheit also wie
gesagt da hilft die sonne und indirekt
mit mach was mit dem ihn indirekt ja
vitamin d was ist das überhaupt wie
bekomme ich das nicht nur durch die
sonne kann ich das auch essen haben wir
alle davon genug und was kann ich tun um
da mein haushalt zu verbessern
dann verabschieden sie sich schon mal
von veganer ernährung
also vitamin d können sie meistens
überschuss produkte aufnehmen
lebertran waren ganz bekannter extrakt
müssen so sehen normalerweise bauen wir
selber mit dem ende auf aber dafür
brauchen die sonne aber sommer etwa nur
20 bis 40 minuten pro tag also
sonnenschein ist raus wenn wir nach
draußen gehen und dann sehr personal
bestimmt eine stunde auf erhalten dort
aber man muss ganz klar sagen wenn sie
aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht schaffen
müssen auch sehen am nordkap gibt es ja
auch sechs monate dunkelheit
da muss man sich durch andere sachen
helfen da vitamin d wie gesagt
fischprodukte lädt auch zum beispiel
lieber also weiter also weniger für die
vegane ernährung er für die fleisch
costa de ungeeignet in den teilen
deutschlands wo es noch nicht regnet
sondern wo es noch schön waren es drängt
es die menschen ja an die badeseen ist
das aus ihrer sicht unbedenklich dort
quasi wie die sardinen zu liegen und ich
schon ein bisschen stürmen
also wenn ich die bilder selber kriege
ich irgendwie
panik und plaque das geht einfach nicht
mehr so ich glaube die leute haben nicht
gesehen was in den usa passiert ja das
haben die auch gefeiert bring back und
so weiter florida ich kann das alles
super nachvollziehen ja auch mir macht
es spaß an der sonne zu sein
am strand zu legen mit freuen uns weiter
alles klar
aber jetzt ist eben die zeit dafür
abstand zu halten und maske und abstand
auch am strand auch wenn es blöd gleich
ist weil sonst laufen wir echt in die
gefahr dass wir sind schon bei der
zweiten meldet dass diese zweite welle
über uns hinüber statt und dann dann
taktischen zerschlägt schauen wir uns
die zahlen den usa die bilder in
brasilien gerade auch sachen wie aus
florida oder kalifornien einen stränden
oder aber auch mal locker was da nicht
ständig oder 8 an den barcelona wollen
wir das wirklich riskiert dass wir jetzt
in zwei volle welle reinlaufen mit magda
uns und so weiter und da hilft es nicht
und da muss auch klar die politik kante
zeigen und dann auch dinge sperren und
auch ausgespannt verein machen und
fahren noch durchsetzen konsequent weil
sonst setzt sich der virus konsequent
durch